ça
et quand je suis bon récemment compromis
ça c'est normal parce que je suis pour
le bayer se connaît un peu tout le monde
joue de la guitare d'une main et puis
d'harmonie cadeau en général joue la
chromatique mais j'en avais une double
affront j'ai est celle-là vous signale
que je leur posais un autre comme ça
j'en ai une
c'est normal ça coûte combien ça que
c'est me demande un truc comme ça dans
la vie il faut pas s'en faire celui qui
sans fin et non celle heureux
et
la liberté de l'air toujours de l'air
normal c'est un sac ce type dans le midi
je pense que je n'oublie pas qu'il a
briefé chaud et puis il y avait pas de
plonger jusqu'à maintenant maintenant là
aussi vous prenez souvent comme ça
j'adore oui de quoi vous occuper il fait
la manche et joue de la musique un peu
un jeu tant le chapeau et je alors c'est
bon place du tertre en ce moment là où
les touristes et les allemands devant
les chefs de troupe
je me démerde un peu dans toutes les
landes et un petit peu fait une salade
russe
pourquoi vous appelle napoléon c'est un
surnom et puis ça m'est toujours resté à
napoléon droite n'a pris tout le monde
le connaît sous le nom de mauléon vous
êtes aussi connu que l'autre est pas si
connue tenir l'autre y était pas la
cloche un disque à l'huile avec du fric
mais moi j'en ai pour encore mieux vous
êtes mariés divorcés devancé normalement
je ne vais pas assez alors ma femme que
je ne vais pas vous voulez me faire
boire de l'eau moi ça marche tout faux
normal alors dans la région repose la
flotte j'étais dans l'avion avant ok là
je voudrais commencer
rochus parti qui avait 17 ans chers
jeunes j'en ai fait sept ans et demi
j'ai revenue à 1 54 temps 49 sur mes
jambes j'étais au 2e bataillon étranger
de préjudice alors j'en ai vus a fait
toutes les couleurs vous grandit alors
maintenant
j'emmerde l'administration j'emmerde les
flics va mettre le monde seulement de
dire je suis anarchiste sans pourtant on
voit et ça c est se paye plein pot
il ya bonne chose et rien beaucoup qui
pensent comme moi croient que son âge je
vais travailler pour combien pour 2012
mais rien faute car vous êtes vous avez
choisi alors carrément d'être coacher
carrément
non
jaloux
certaines pékin à l'occasion du week-end
m
il ya longtemps que vous vous avez des
là dedans
bah ça fait presque quatre mois
quelques mois et avant les voitures ah
si j'en ai les douze mois j'étais marié
17 ont alors henri maritale et puis tout
va passer d'un seul coup à mal
et toc est déglingué lincou et qu'est ce
qu'on faisait comme boulot avant a été
peinte en voiture
votre voiture voit gagnais bien ma vie
mais je suis tombé malade et puis il
suffit alors plus de boulot plus rien à
y serait allé bouffer et o latorre
archives il business wanda à droite
avoue enfin défendre comme on peut quoi
un écho vous serez vieux au dépôt peur
d'aller à nantes et on fait comme ça
alors non quand je serai vieux bars à
chats mais demeurer toujours pour nous
un petit coin la campagne piaf ou très
commentée en bourgogne avant j'aurai
toujours une branche ma famille j'allais
la voir avant et voilà les enfants qui
une fille elle est mariée
longtemps
et là clermont
au jambon et léché méchant et il est
bien placé
by son sahara est une écrit et me dit
viens bien et là bas et il sera bien et
kova non moi j'aime mon la dépendance
j'aime bien tout seul voilà ça me plaît
de faire ça je le fais ah ouais comme ça
c'est que vous avez gardé le produit on
se bat ça souvenirs et ça c'est c'est
difficile à expliquer vous y reste
attachée
parce que j'étais variés qu'une femme la
première elle est morte alors j'ai
toujours gardé mon alliance n'a jamais
quitté québec quittera jamais
p
ça me
ça nous fait toujours pas toujours parce
que monsieur roger aujourd'hui monsieur
qui a trop souffert comme ça pour nous
les pros malheureux mais non l'ancien
militaire et tout ça c'est pour ça
qu'ils nous donnent à manger
il ya combien de temps que vous êtes le
militaire ça fait un bout de temps j'ai
quitté monsieur ont été malades après
voilà et venait pas de pas de pension de
moi j'ai pas de pension lançait copains
étaient là avant et j'ai perdu ma mère
ma mère et mon père pendant l'occupation
allemande
oui j'aime bien mon père riche et noyé
accident de travail
j'ai perdu ma mère après j'étais tout
seul me suis débrouillé j'ai travaillé
dans le bâtiment et il ya eu la
libération je suis parti j'avais 16 ans
dans l'armée
j'ai combattu jules aqualiens météo avec
étoile de bronze
j'ai demandé l'un qui étaient aux
anciens combattants derrière moi je vais
fait deux séjours la voix en a deux ou
quatre ans j'ai 6 juin six ans de
service ils tendent compagnie
normalement j'aurais loire emploi dans
un emploi de réserver et comme j'ai 43
ans
vous comprenez je suis trop vieux pour
certaines entreprises
si je rentre mettront à la ville je suis
trop vieux
comprenez ce que je voulais alors si à
moi de me débrouiller
il ya beaucoup d'anciens militaires qui
sont dans notre situation il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup y en a à
partir de 40 ou 43 cents ou dit monsieur
est trop vieux voilà voilà la chose et
c'est bien vrai c'est bien la vérité ça
ça joue sajou il cache pas ça je vous le
cache pas
c'est la vérité est connue
là
jamais depuis hier
mais
pour moi personnellement je profite mais
en dehors que dormir dans les centres
d'accueil de paris s'est plaint dette
c'est un coup c'est plein de deux tours
mais en hiver pour dire non mais non
bien sûr que non
ces prêts
combien de temps que vous êtes de ces
deux ans 200 que vous demandez pourquoi
j'ai perdu dans la division de voitures
ma femme mes deux filles
dans le 17ème avec une 404 un canot qui
m'est rentré dedans
j'ai passé deux mois deux mois à sainte
anne comme pas dingue mais presque et on
m'a laissé liberté provisoire sur
surveillance médicale
on m'a dit que j'étais fou mais preuve
alors en sortent donc la casquette
voilà
peux-tu tous avaient décidé de pas
quel effet ça fait la première fois
alors qu'on trouve dans la rue si de
dire ça dépend les copains qu'on trouve
si on a un petit morceau de pain à
manger on sait le partage dans trois ou
quatre malades
si on n'a rien mangé dans on mange rien
mais en air au moins libre
de vieux mais rechercher un boulot je
m'intéresse plus pourquoi pourquoi on y
croit
j'ai eues j'étais mariée j'ai eu ma
femme mais depuis aujourd'hui que je
vais rétablir nos prénoms
on sera génial et décisive en deux de
front plus de lui dans le
bourassa
lamballe il attendra
mieux que ça
h école doit c'est attaquable tournée
j'ai pas tout
on l'appelle d'arc montre que c'est lui
c'est lui
la map
m
alors on grandit au niveau mondial
par ailleurs un boulot en q3 alors la
belle machine et marionnettes en bronze
et un ça va
on renverra heures marché mais on va
vous êtes toujours chasse à canon
après je vais un peu de courtage bidon
on voit les petites bricoles convoi pour
sa porte
matyassy tapis si oui mais l'artisan a
plaisamment les tient à coeur de ses
salles à voir dans le temps une
situation j'étais trop jeune vous êtes
mariés vous avez des matelas au site
non non sinon on était mariée en face à
beja de van den berg fauriel à côté de
ça c'est encore 1,5 comme on compte bien
faire ici à ma foi si on proposait de
faire un boulot nous faut faire
on les laisse passer quelque chose non
les versions l'a choisi la liberté
karti foule a choisi on l'a prouvé une
fois que vous l'avez choisie c'est bien
la faute libertaire faut aller jusqu'au
bout qu faut pas dire aujourd'hui bonne
idée ça va au public demain ça va pas
tandis que nous on a choisi la maison
lenoble la garder jusqu'au bout nous la
liberté et je gardais messieurs je suis
pour que commun comme déjà des jeunes
qui disent maintenant gbagbo se plaît
ici sont bonnes a de se marier
et seuls coupables se pose une chose une
panne grave à peu nous replacer dit elle
dégringole celle de l'angola bouton
tandis que 1 alors à sa place a dû
retrouver un vieux carl icahn car
j'avais trouvé un but car 70 ils ont
créé un genre de proposition donc on a
tous à dire mais si les sommes non mais
le barman hollande à aubry ou alors ici
ou ailleurs ils ont aimé leur femme
fille normale puis l'autre où aller
jusqu'à quel âge on peut faire ce métier
jusqu'à quel âge oui déjà dépensé au
calme et on tient ses problèmes at-elle
terre s'est mise à peur là et tiercé
mais a peur on s'est dit bon je crois
que mon avenir de la langue c'est pas
une affaire on ne sait pas une sinécure
ça s'est passé avec mon arrivée au
moment où des armes à ce moment là on va
se motoriser sais quoi et moi j'étais
mobile edge comme ça je mettrai la
voiture via un bras derrière
non ça n'est pas compliqué ni le bon
dieu
justin que me tenais tube d'analysé
voulez pas vous tenez le coup là avec la
femme n'est pas parce beaucoup jettent à
dire en temps en temps mais la [ __ ] de
coin arrêt pl montant ne tient que moi
je sais je veux dire la bosnie en temps
et je sais qu'un maintien d'europe 1
alors à ce moment là je vois qu'à me
raconte des histoires un peu trop long
aux valeurs l'action du japon -1 pt
eh bien on n'arrête non maraudage lui
non leurs avants de pointe avait tu
racontes totalisé nationale casquette
j'aiderai j'aurai je pose une question
ouais je vais poser une question au polo
la lazio est un problème avec les femmes
robert comtois expliquer cela quand
couche
enfin tout ce clochard tous ensemble se
trouve la zone et projet 5,6 à des pros
et l'envoya dépassé par téléphone j'ai
commencé la femme d'un copain toujours
une touche pop si jamais nous sommes des
droits mais c'est difficile de trouver
de finances milieu comment c'est pas
difficile est pas un coup de rouge je
vous ai dit avait commencé positivement
et un millionnaire oui monsieur papa
internationale à l'international où
monsieur vous avez tout plaquer tout
l'accusé doubout fait ville à pékin
après avoir infligé des coureurs grassi
14 ans de maison
elle couvre de me tuer deux maisons du
manoir troisième accroche à des douleurs
ou
où est-ce qu'ils habitaient en général
moins de maisons abandonnées ou cdm et
chris bosh oasis bulls à machiné on
vient les mecs larmes au jurés ils
profitent des progrès
pierre
merci
merci madame l infirmière huilé vous
enregistrez vous prenez la lumière j'ai
trois ans en france et s'appelle
jean-pierre et deux filles dont mais les
gendres souvent politique dans ce jeu
les événements appelé à mon secours mot
sur et j'ai dû porter par contre obtenir
un peu d'argent et quimerc'h pauvreté
mais pas vis mais j'étais heureuse de
trouver cet asile
google
en italie
allez ça va merci matières premières
seul versement
je pars est un des lieux très beau pour
l'énerver 7 et votre temps le
championnat et on l'a vu chez lez
mortagne personne et vous l'avez laissée
à la personne ben oui mais alors comment
voulez vous que je reçoive des soucis
vous vous avez laissé le talent sommes
un bon pas cher chercher le mal elle
voit le chèche le talent la poste un
homme sans talent en faire partie bénard
la caisse est longée par jean marc four
c'est le facteur qui la donne un violent
coup de gueule journalistes comme nous
je suis là senna c'est le kilo germé
dans ma ferme ta gueule des gens qui
passent des questions à la télévision et
le pensons a real
elle de nous trouver des morceaux
taillés l'amour peut-être s'est
embarquée aimons-nous ce soit sans
songer à ce que de ma peu changé au fil
de l'eau fois le cerveau ce n'est que
sur terre
déjà les réponses
pourquoi ils s'appellent poitiers
la pj en avant aux à poitiers rend non
non vous êtes vous dit non
dès lors où il entend que ce produit a
paris une vingtaine d'années oui
et qu'est ce que faisait quand vous êtes
venu à paris j'étais très bien xavier
métier vous oui vous étiez marié oui
je suis comme une cloche qui a trois ans
l'imposant oui qu'est-ce que c'est
arrivé
mon ami est tombé malade est tombé au
sol et je n'ai pas pu payer la chambre
est devenu plus mais où est-ce que vous
dormez en général dans la rue à la rue
oui est ce que vous voulez
autrement je n'aurais pas été si je
retourne dans le nord oui je réponds bah
pas mieux
on a maintenant et voilà pourquoi je te
veux une cloche alors vous en sortez
comment dans les poubelles à google oui
vous vendez des chiffons aussi non non
non je ne dis pas qu elles ne valent
rien d'abord je ne suis pas capable de
faire la main je n'ai pas été élevé
comme ça c'est très difficile de faire
la manche quand nous n'avons pas été
élevé comme ça il a fallu je vous dise
une chose que je tombe d'un vagabondage
le cheval malade je ne savais pas où
j'étais malade je n'étais pas au courant
quand il ya eu les prélèvements on a dit
mais vous êtes du barde
je suis pas bacillaire mais je suis
libéré et à mon âge pour les audaces et
ou même 50 sec
je voudrais tourner nos matches
retourner dans mon pays car lille
merci pour pour mourir
on retrouvera
sur une grille
c'est tout ce qu'on ne retrouvera
et pas d'eau à l'horizon colonies d'où
quelques voulait faire on dira balles
est mort comme john de poitiers mais
c'est tout qu'est-ce que je fasse ça
arrive commence à peine plus cher un
jour surtout par l'alcool à l'alcool
mais aussi la fainéantise et
accueillante et jeté ma grosse je saurai
pas joué alors tu travailles tu point
d'acheter au comptant et demi je n'y a
pas de boulot tous les jours mes parents
je lui disais que c'est à cause de
l'alcool là mais on commence tôt avoir
très bien que sheila je vous dire c'est
une délivrance pour wii et nos ennuis
on n'oublie rien on s'habitue c'est tout
c'est un petit coup de froid l'hiver
quand tu veux croire
la durance vous avez tous un métier on a
tous un métier la plupart des occasions
moi je suis plombier mais comme j'étais
à l'intérieur maintenant je peux plus le
faire ce travail et maintenant je suis
obligé de vivre comme tout le monde en
dehors de la société c'est-à-dire en se
formant une société nouvelle société des
crachats et automatiquement on est très
ennuyé lors il faut l'alcool pour se
soutenir et ça nous permet de gagner un
peu d'argent cet alcool justement c'est
à dire ça nous permettait à la manche de
trouver s'emballe par là où ils
s'emballent par là pour acheter un litre
et puis il a acheté un casse croûte et
on vit continuer à en arriver tous à se
connaître et on est en général tous
fermés tous camarades ses enfants ce
qu'est ce qui lui donne si on passait
pas juste on dit ici à new york la garde
le doigt les pieds de loi qui nous nous
aimons comme je m'appelle loire le lourd
mais moi j'ai internationale de
lagardère était en visite d'usiné et
puis vous avez pensionnaires
conditionneuse n'importe quoi vous ai
fait mon petit nom et d'aventuré l'école
de quoi ah oui à baconnes gila c'est
vrai
mais j'ai une chose que j'aime je lis et
là vous êtes jaloux de votre mari l'a au
moins un jour par balles londres a
jamais vraiment pas toi personnel a reçu
quoi commencer ça vous croit et il est
belle
il a pas de trop bien sa seconde j'aime
bien divergents tvt crise de palu chine
région je suis à l'hôtel ex à qui prend
la porte dans sa bouche en dieu quel
qu'il soit
j'ai eu peur
voilà même dit qu'est ce qui se passe
pour les dames les gauches peuvent
achats
j'ai besoin de vous de serviettes froide
sur la tête
il adore migrants faire et j'ai quitté
un baume bourogne cédric je vais et le
mérite peut-être ne le mérite pas du
tout ancien membre
comment ça s'est passé à l'hôpital
j'hésiterais bien passé je dis que
j'étais bien soyez tous mais que je
m'ennuyais qui ne venaient pas me voir
vous inquiétez pour lui ou pour vous non
parce que je jalouse car exemple l on
aime quelqu'un il faut pas le laisser
est ce qu'on prend conscience la
première fois lorsqu'on est appelée à
dormir dans la rue a conscience que ça
peut être ça va être dur
monter parce qu'on s'en rend compte
qu'on soit rencontre
les maillots hungaria parce que on peut
pas payer la chambre d'hôtel qui font
qu'on mange avant vers nous on est mieux
manger et pour payer le château on sait
que cette solution provisoire ça mais
c'est provisoire qu'on appelle les
cheminots talent c'est provisoire mais
ça dure un peu de trop car tout le temps
des pots en prison ou à l'hôpital
et à force on peut vous perdez pas
courage confiance
la rage
on dit toujours à chaque jour suffit sa
peine et l'avenir comme
l avenir je la vois avec du travail
je peux avoir comme en gros bourg à
sortir ce que sale p puis à clé bleue
on a les bus toute la journée yacine car
il ya un quart à le matin et à leurs
sept heures et demie pour 7 à 10 heures
encore un quart à midi et encore un
quart après l'après midi elles soient
les flics quoi alors alors pour ce
progrès
attends la feria
la date de naissance la classe 30
donc cette famille là 100 % disent
qu'ils ont créé
la minorité
22 devant 32
le néo nazis dans les rizières ou
l'appeler l'un des shows sur cette
[ __ ] week-end il y avait très peu donc
on s'en fout
quoique
au total
saf
non
vous avez département de la cause
au jeune femme c'est pareil c'est le
département la crue d'arrondissement
guéri
pas pire début
en prenant
bon
on
c'est le rapport qu'ils avaient pas une
prime au nombre ça n'arriverait pas
c'est ça qu'il faudrait leur supprimer
propos n'est pas ce qu'on à vouloir
certains n'attendent pas après l'autre
nanterre se débarbouiller comme
d'habitude vous allez
il ya d asile pour nous
mais naturellement et à grand peine un
point de l'espoir moi j'ai des amis une
samba d'or et que vous perdez pas oui la
crème en prenant bien aussi
idole enfin quoi la terrasse
moi ce que je revienne pas en 2000 à
shenzhen j'ai eu beaucoup de relations
tu fais comment ça se fait que vous êtes
retrouvées sans logement
et parce que parce que les valider
j'ai mal accompagné alors l'arrêt des
plus habiles à fond
bush non mais vous avez la maison unis
saluent faustini mac c'est pas vous qui
commandés
ces lunettes c'est pas rigoler garde
alors
on
vous êtes des habitués de nanterre
toujours jour tous les mois
bon pourquoi vous ne travaillez plus
qu'elles sont pas suffisamment payés
ah bon être gay et d'irène pas
suffisamment payés et à l'extérieur vous
faites quelque chose
malheureusement reviennent sortir
d'affaires de jardin vital comment ça se
fait que vous venez vous demander de
venir ici on vous ramène toi vous genre
un peu volontaire parce qu'on ne veut
pas coucher dehors en fonds propres
quand même vous avez judor oui mais j'ai
attaqué j'ai une vente trouvait alors il
ya autant que vous venez comme ça à
nanterre règlement fermés depuis que je
connais les bleus se déliter blade une
dizaine d'années et vous soucier si les
paroles et disant ah oui et grands avant
qu'on jette le lait il ya longtemps que
cette recherche vous loi au nom local
j'habitais à lyon et je faisais un
travail là bas on vous faisait un
travail d'abord à l'eau plus travailler
dans la caf et comme serveuse où et
comment ça se fait que vous avez arrêté
les bains c'est un mec qui m'a mené à
paris m'a dit tu viens à paris on envoie
des fleurs et m'a laissé tomber dès que
ces tags à paris la wii et vous n'aviez
pas de logement mais il faut payer pour
le jeu et vous y avez devant vous venez
ici c'est traumatisant le puits 60
ah bon vous connaissez vous avez
travaillé avant ah oui qu'est ce que
c'est mais plus retombé de travail que
je vais tomber malade et un sanatorium à
trouver du travail je me trouvais sur
les puits de terre normalement posé la
question et spiritueux petite forme
depuis salage est essentielle intérieurs
sont intérieurement restait plus qu'à
cueillir et puis pas de logement pas la
même qu'en général et une femme sur ce
coup son logis ou simple que ça vienne
quoi en général ça va ça vient de quoi
en général lorsqu'on est lorsqu'une
femme se retrouve dehors sert nième fois
la mise et la misère la maladie en
général la maladie la misère perçu un
peu de famille pour former les hommes
disent qu'en général ça cause des femmes
qui se retrouvent leur fatigue commence
à se faire appeler beaucoup plus
d'hommes que de femmes
je parlais plus de finir celle du sang
paraissent employés et vous avez fait la
manche pour moi je les fait dimanche et
ça vous amène à vous apporter un
meilleur jour alors des fois on se fait
virer
lorsque brusquement fin on n'a plus
d'argent
est-ce qu'on devient très vite pêcheurs
oui oui malheureusement oui
est-ce qu'on accepte très vite de ce
qu'on s'habitue vite ça c'est très dur
la fille habitait
vous allez vous non je n'ai pas tout
seul au monde
et vous pareillement et moi toucher aux
morts depuis l'âge de 19 ans
vous avez commencé toit a trait à
présent possible et c'est tout comment
vous avez commencé tôt à travailler à
travailler j'avais qu'elle a pu la tenir
dans mes poches dans les vosges
et vous qu'est ce que vous faisiez je
suis enceinte prostituées c'est la loge
oui horrible également dû avoir vous
n'avez pas l'argent de côté
jean ministres ont tellement tomber
malade vous savez gravement malade j'ai
tout mangé pas les hôpitaux
il ya beaucoup d'anciennes prostituées
qui se et pour quelle raison parce
qu'elles sont exploités ou un peu ça
cela se prostituent veut augmenter
oui
devic vous êtes seul ça vous manque les
marines ont bombardé podium royal voilà
sur balles et de ça quelques places pour
les jeunes c'est plus difficile pour une
femme d'être notre coach a que toi même
je ne peux pas vous dire monsieur moi je
ne fréquente pas les hommes vous savez
on chante en dix ans
je m'excuse de vous le dire
ce ne sont pas mes amis
et je suis arrivé dans la misère on a
fait beaucoup